- Welcome, everyone.
Thank you for joining me online
to celebrate the accomplishments
of the students of the Class of 2020.
To the graduating students,
I am grateful that we
can gather as a community
in this way to honor all
that you have achieved.
However, this is no
replacement for Commencement.
When it is safe to do so,
I will welcome you back to campus
to participate in a
traditional Yale graduation
with your classmates.
In the meantime,
your deans and I
officially mark your
graduation from Yale this year.
We recognize the extraordinary work
all of you have completed
in your programs of study.
We salute your effort, your
diligence, your talent,
and your intellect.
We also join you in expressing gratitude
for all who have supported
you in these endeavors.
Your families and friends,
professors, and other members
of the Yale community.
It is now my great pleasure
to officially confer
your Yale degrees.
To those who have completed
your degree requirements,
you have been recommended by
the faculty of your school
and your dean has asked
me by my official act
to confer upon you your degree.
With the approval of the Yale Corporation
and by the authority vested in me,
I confer upon you your degree
as designated by your dean
and admit you to all its
rights and responsibilities.
Some of you
will complete your degree
requirements after today.
When you have been recommended
by the faculty of your school
and approved by the Yale Corporation,
your dean shall ask me by my official act
to confer upon you your degree.
By the authority vested in me,
I shall confer upon you your degree
when designated by the dean
and shall then admit you
to all its rights and responsibilities.
Congratulations to the Class of 2020.